hey legal eagles it's true a little
while ago this youtube channel did in
fact
file suit against the white house the
cia the doj the department of state
and a whole bunch of other government
agencies on twitter and youtube i asked
for the questions that you had
about this particular lawsuit and you
did not disappoint i got over 2
000 questions about this ongoing suit
and
since this is a great opportunity to
take you guys along for the ride
i thought i would try and answer some of
the most common questions that you had
about this lawsuit now i'll start off by
answering one of the most common
questions which is
why and i think that the point of this
lawsuit was misunderstood by a lot of
people the point of this lawsuit is
governmental transparency which
i dare to say i think most people should
be in favor of more governmental
transparency especially
into a part of government review that is
not particularly well known and is
famously opaque and that is the
pre-publication review process for
people that have classified information
and then want to write a book
and famously this is something that
governments
don't want people to know very much
about and under the circumstances it
really looks like there were some
political shenanigans that got in the
way of john bolton being able to
publish one or more different
manuscripts of his book
for political reasons not for national
security reasons
and a suit like this only works when
the government does something that it
shouldn't that it prevents
a former government official from being
able to disclose information that he or
she
should be able to disclose if the
government had
upheld the the standards of
pre-publication review
the lawsuit wouldn't have anywhere to go
because everything would have been
properly classified
given what we know it seems that that is
incredibly unlikely and that some things
were prohibited from being disclosed
that really shouldn't have been
and a lot of people also misunderstood
what we are trying to accomplish here
which is that
remember john bolton submitted an
original manuscript of his book to the
government
then they went through a whole process
uh saying what he could and could not
publish
and then they said he was okay to
publish and then reneged on that
agreement when a political appointee
came in after the career
administrator said that the book was
clear to go
so the the point of the foyer requests
is uh
not seeking the book that has already
been published but
going towards the original book that
john bolton wanted to publish
even before the initial pre-publication
review
and on top of that we're also looking
for the communications
amongst the government officials in
terms of what considerations were they
thinking about when they said john
bolton could and could not publish
things is there correspondence with
michael ellis the political appointee
saying that john bolton couldn't publish
his book for political reasons
and then of course there's the question
of what standards if any did they use
to decide whether john bolton could
publish the information
in his book so we're seeking a lot of
different kinds of documents and
not just the book that was published but
the original book that john bolton
wanted to publish and
the correspondence about the
pre-publication review process and what
standards if any
they were using and even if the
government didn't disclose anything
other than
explaining who did the redactions of
john bolton's book
even that would be incredibly important
information to
get a glimpse into whether the
redactions were
correct or not and on top of that when
the us government responds to a foia
request they have to provide
way more specificity than they do when
they're conducting the pre-publication
review process
in pre-pub review they can basically say
remove this information and not really
give you
a reason why when responding to foia
they
have to tell us if they were removing
information because it was classified or
for some other
reason so even getting those responses
would be a win
because if they told john bolton that
they were removing things because it was
classified and then tell us in their
foia requests
that the information wasn't classified
well then we know that there were real
shenanigans going on in the
pre-publication
review process in a way that absolutely
should not happen and this particular
suit on behalf of legal eagle
it's not entirely new we're standing on
the shoulders of some real giants in the
world
of foia and of governmental transparency
organizations like crew muckrock
judicial watch back in the day
all of these organizations are the real
unsung heroes
of foia and are really the ones that are
working every day
to disclose things that the us
government doesn't want
people to see so we are following in the
trail that they have already blazed and
we're indebted to those kind of
organizations that are working
every day to further governmental
transparency now
this particular lawsuit is different for
some reasons that we will
talk about and there are some
interesting implications of it but with
that being said
let's dive into all of your particular
questions about this lawsuit
okay so one of the most popular
questions i got is a variation of this
question that was asked by
user agma schwa who asks how much does
it cost to sue something like the white
house
now when you're talking about lawsuits
there are generally two big things that
cost the most and they're divided into
costs
and fees costs are things like how much
it costs to file the lawsuit
how much it costs to do the various
transactional things like
have a court reporter and then there are
the the much
bigger things that are called fees and
that generally refers to how much it
costs for your lawyer
and in the absence of a fee shifting
statute you got to pay for your own
your own lawyer in this particular case
it costs 400
to file a federal lawsuit that's pretty
standard
then it'll cost probably a few thousand
dollars in terms of other filing fees
uh and things related to court reporters
and uh
stenographers for depositions if we get
there which
for reasons we won't go into we probably
won't so on the order
uh in terms of the actual uh raw fees
you're talking uh several thousand
dollars
then when you're talking about attorneys
believe it or not in washington dc
probably an average
cost of an attorney is 500 an hour the
really
really good uh big firm attorneys you're
probably talking about
a thousand twelve hundred dollars an
hour so
for the kind of things that you're
talking about in this litigation it's
gonna cost
definitely a few hundred hours of
attorney time so you guys can do the
math on that
so obviously the big x factor is how
many hours of the attorney's time are
you going to need to be able to propound
something like this
and you know on at the very minimum
you're talking tens of thousands of
dollars of attorney time and it could be
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
attorney time if you're talking about
taking this on appeal
which is particularly likely in a case
like this so yeah
lawyers in lawsuits very expensive uh
which takes us to
the next question uh by a user named
isporov jr
question have any suits against the
white house succeeded in the past
and if so how frequently does this
happen so actually
i can point you to one very recent
example of a
pretty similar lawsuit that was very
very successful and there is a
journalist
at buzzfeed whose name is jason leopold
who
has done a lot of great stuff related to
the mueller report
and recently mr leopold filed a foia
request and then
a foia lawsuit to enforce his foia
requests
to try and get the unredacted mueller
report
and as a result lots of the portions of
the original mueller report
were revealed and further portions of
the mueller report
were shown with more specificity as to
why they were redacted and not revealed
so that is an example of a successful
similar suit that as a result of
jason leopold and buzzfeed we now know a
lot more about the original mueller
report we don't know
everything but we do know that large
portions were redacted when they
probably shouldn't have been
he's going to continue we'll probably
get even more portions of the mueller
report
and in terms of successful and how often
they're successful
well it depends on what you mean in
terms of getting some
of the previously redacted information
and getting more specificity as to why
other things were redacted in the first
place
happens pretty frequently it's rare that
you get all of the documents that you
want
but in terms of holding the government's
feet to the fire and getting more
information
which is part of the reason for this
particular suit
it happens with some regularity okay
user jldaydream
asks since you've sued the white house
are you actually allowed to comment on
this as it's now an ongoing case
that is a very good question as we've
talked about a lot on this channel it's
a really really bad idea for most people
to go out and talk about ongoing
litigation
that being said uh this video will be
approved
so the odds of me saying something that
are incredibly prejudicial to my case
are
probably pretty low but this is an
example of
do as i say not as i do if you find
yourself in litigation or a lawsuit
or in trouble with the government best
to let your lawyers handle everything
but also by the same token
don't take legal advice from youtube
channel
not legal advice all right user tragic
solitude asks
how difficult is it to sue something as
big as entire departments of the
government
well it's not the easiest thing in the
world
all right so user just a poet asks so is
this the same as suing the united states
government or is the white house in this
context an entity of its own
that's a great question we are suing
several different agencies and entities
within the government
um so when i say the white house i'm
actually referring to
a couple of different departments and
primarily i'm we are suing
the uh national security council which
john bolton
was uh the head of he was the national
security adviser
that is one of the large portions we're
also suing other
agencies within the government that
probably had access to john bolton's
book and might have participated in the
pre-publication review process
and so that's why we're suing entities
like the cia and the department of
justice and
a whole bunch of other entities so i
refer to that generally as the white
house but we're actually suing
a bunch of different entities all
because they
play different roles with respect to
this uh this scenario
okay uh next question is one swedish
fish
oh too bad you only have one swedish
fish swedish fish are great
how long do you think this whole ordeal
will last so this lawsuit is going to
take several different forms and
the over time uh different things will
be adjudicated and the first thing that
we have to do
is uh make sure that legal eagles foia
requests the original ones are entitled
to what's called expedited review
because
for among other things this information
about john bolton's book
and the process that happened and the
information that he was trying to
divulge
are really important it was presumably
part and parcel to
the whole impeachment saga and it could
be
very well relevant to the election in
november so
the foia requests themselves need to be
adjudicated to be
expedited so that they can be processed
in a much quicker way
so in terms of getting a court to order
that these requests are indeed
related to a compelling interest and are
entitled to expedited review
that could be on the order of a few
months and then we get into the
substantive responses
to the foyer requests which include more
information
about the pre-publication review what
happened in terms of the political
concerns
and then of course the responses
regarding john bolton's book in the
first place so that will
probably take much longer that you're
probably looking to six months to
a year and there are some legal issues
here that may require the court of
appeals to weigh in here so
you're definitely looking at a
multi-month multi-year even
process with respect to all this stuff
so it's going to be a long long process
okay so that brings us to user just kaz
who asks
what would be the worst possible outcome
that you'll face moving forward with
this well
other than being suicided by the cia
there were so many comments that people
were like uh oh man it's gonna be
terrible when
legal eagle commits suicide by being
shot twice in the back of the head
we've got some definitely uh some
gallows humor going on here putting that
aside really it's
that this is just gonna take a really
really long
time and that the information that we're
able to get the government to disclose
um is minimal we're gonna fight like
hell to make sure that that doesn't
happen
we have some legal issues with respect
to the national security council
i think we'll be able to overcome those
but it's possible that uh court of
appeals might disagree with us but
that's
one of the reasons why there are other
government entities here because
uh some of the concerns with respect to
the nsc don't really
apply to the other governmental agencies
here
and so we should be able to get some
information
eventually it's just going to take a
really really long time and actually
now is a great time to thank all of you
out there
the outpouring of support uh regarding
my first videos when we
we broached the the lawsuit was
astonishing and we're still getting the
preliminary numbers
in but the outpouring of the donations
to the non-profit
the national security councilors who are
handling the nuts and bolts of this
litigation was
amazing and i can't divulge all the
information but i can say
that because of your support this will
not be
a one-off piece of litigation we will
go forward in the future with other
lawsuits related to governmental
transparency and
i want to make it clear the donations
that everyone made to the national
security councillors
through democracy engine none of that
goes to me
personally or to legal eagle the company
that all goes to the non-profit the
national security councillors who are
committed to governmental transparency
and this will not be
a one-off collaboration we are going to
make sure that we
do some other stuff in the future so you
know if you guys have any ideas about
other things that we can do in the name
of governmental transparency uh you know
let us know
because uh we're gonna be working
together in the future okay so
a user whose username is just a
seemingly random series of letters
asks what does the central intelligence
agency have to do with this
this sounds like more of an fbi matter
well that is a great question
with respect to john bolton remember he
was the national security advisor so he
was privy to a lot of different
information
and worked with a lot of different
governmental agencies
and the thing about the pre-publication
review process is that
when there is sensitive information or
potentially classified information or
potentially
prohibited information instead of having
one agency
do the review you often give
the source material to a bunch of
different agencies that
are responsible for that particular
thing when he
submitted his book to the government the
national security council for
pre-publication review
the nsc probably gave that book to other
agencies so they can do their own
review including the cia so that is one
of the reasons why we have sued all
these different agencies is because
they had access to the book presumably
and they are subject to foia
and we want to know what concerns they
had what they told john bolton
to remove and and what they said he
could not publish
so that's why in this particular case
the cia and not the fbi is the
particular agency
to get foia in this particular case okay
let's see user elizabeth henning
asks this seems like the kind of lawsuit
newspapers file when their foia requests
are ignored or denied
and this is a matter of considerable
national interest are any uh press
outlets joining you
in the suit so elizabeth you're
absolutely right on this is exactly that
kind of suit
and there are other organizations that
do this kind of thing all the time
in particular one i'm particularly fond
of is called crew
it's the citizens for responsibility and
ethics in washington
they do a great job of really getting to
the heart of important matters
foyering them and being capable of
taking those suits to court
to be able to enforce their foia
requests so if you believe
in the mission of governmental
transparency and you believe in the
mission
of this particular lawsuit i would
highly recommend checking out crew and
muckrock
um they do this kind of thing all the
time
this lawsuit is different i hinted at
that before because
we're taking the the nsc the national
security council head on which
is something that a lot of these
organizations
um aren't willing to do for for various
reasons
we think it this particular incidence
with
john bolton especially given the
impeachment saga
and and now john bolton's book and
potentially the the election in november
incredibly important and so we're
willing to put in the time and go
further with this lawsuit than often
some organizations
um are some for for very good reasons
but we wholeheartedly believe
in the mission of those other
organizations uh
in fighting corruption that you need
transparency from the government
especially
when things are this important and the
stakes are so high
all right so that takes me to uh user
rockery
which asks how do you even subpoena a
government agency
like who do you send notices to i wanted
to answer this question
because that has been such a huge saga
there are procedures for this kind of
thing but given that we live
not only in a world where it's hard to
sue the government uh and
to to be able to serve process so we
haven't served subpoenas so much as foia
requests and then
the serving process of the the complaint
on these government agencies
but also we're dealing with copid and
everyone's working from home
the shenanigans that the various
government agencies have been pulling
with respect to
not accepting service of things that
they absolutely should be accepting
service on
changing their addresses saying that we
need to send notices to different people
not accepting the mail like the us post
office is having a hard time getting a
hold of these various agencies
it's been a mess and it's been sort of
hilarious and
maybe this is just the sort of thing
that the lawyers who are total wonks
about this thing
find interesting but it's been a crap
shoot and it's been a whole thing
i can't wait to tell you about it at
some point all right and then finally
user paolo emanuel tavarez asks given
how
politically charged your case is do you
think that the courts might delay the
decision until after the election
so i sort of dispute the fact that this
is a politically charged case
this is about governmental transparency
i think everyone on both sides of the
aisle
thinks that john bolton's information is
probably pretty
important and if the government did
everything right
and wasn't playing games with classified
information then
that's important to know and we can take
faith in the government conducting
pre-publication review if it turns out
that's not the case
that perhaps we should support john
bolton and we should be really
really mad that the government censored
his information if it was for political
reasons so it doesn't seem like
governmental transparency
should be a political issue in terms of
how the judiciary is going to react to
this
i don't think they're going to care one
way or the other federal judges are
very very independent federal judges
especially at the district court level
are really just umpires
they apply the law to the facts and the
law is
pretty cut and dry so i would not be
particularly concerned about any
particular federal judge
playing political games in this
particular case now that being said i
can't thank the national security
councilors enough for handling the
lion's share of this litigation
but i do need to spill some legal tea
because one of the biggest questions i
got is
why is the website for the national
security counselor so
terrible so many of you donated to them
but also left
admittedly accurate snarky comments
about their particular website they are
great lawyers but their website needs
work and
they're working on it now when i need a
new domain for a website i go to hover
and maybe we should just scrap the old
nfc website and create a specialty
website like suethewhitehouse.com or
release the bolton cut and if we do
we'll go to hover because that's the
best place on the internet to get
yourself a domain name in part because
they have over 400 domain extensions to
choose from ranging from
dot com to dot io dot me to dot ninja
and dot pizza
and one of the great things about hover
is that they have lots of domains that
you wouldn't normally think of for
example
i got legaleagle.tv from hover and
while i haven't set up that website yet
at least i have that domain ready to go
when
i'm ready to create a website for that
and i did actually set up a website
called legaleagleprep.com for the
website that i have that helps law
students
and it's super easy to buy a domain on
hover there are no annoying upsells no
pop-ups
and if you have an account like i do you
can get another domain in less than 30
seconds or
just check to see if the website of your
dreams is available and once you set up
your own personal domain hover also has
the tools to set up a professional email
address as well because you never want
to be that lawyer that uses an aol
or earthlink email address don't be like
steven biss
and you can also use hover's connect
feature to easily hook up that domain to
website builders like squarespace wix
and shopify
of course the best part is that if you
go over to hover.com legaleagle
which you'll find in the description
below you'll get 10 off of your first
domain purchase
again all you have to do is go to
hover.com legaleagle or click on the
link in the description
to get 10 off your first domain plus
clicking on that link really helps out
this channel
so do you have other questions about the
bolton lawsuit
leave your questions in the comments and
check out this playlist over here with
all of my other
legal videos and legal reactions so
click on this playlist
and i'll see you in court